even in that realm michael parter who's  6 10.  everyone else is six eight or shorter so  bull balls had that advantage  here's bobo on the break finishing with  the reverse  bobo behind the back then behind the  head getting 11 points here in the  fourth  these are the best behind the back get  it back  and throw it down on the reverse  i don't know what you're going to say  you're up 27 four minutes to go but  i would at least try and ball ball with  another impressive play  that was a tough pass to just bring in  if he gets to a place where he's playing  freely he could be a viable option for  them  in that rotation but he's got to get to  a place where he's got that comfort  level going where he understands the  system  inside and out on both ends of the floor  how they want to utilize him this summer  here at summer league is they're going  to give him a nikola jokic type of roll  where when he's playing the five a lot  of the offenses